what we're going to do in this video is
talk about different population growth
strategies for different species and
think about if we can come up with a
broad categorization or if there's a
broad categorization already out there
for us
so we see that there are species like
elephants that are
long-lived in the wild
an african elephant can live roughly as
long as a human being can
50 60 70 in some cases 80 years
you also have things like killer whales
that are also long-lived
you have things like human beings that
live a pretty good long time compared to
other things
in nature you have things like gorillas
that are also reasonably long-lived live
many many many decades
now there's also other patterns that you
see on these
large mammals they tend to well they
tend to be large
they especially if you think about
compared to very small things in the
animal kingdom
they tend to not have a lot of
children every reproductive event i
guess you could say it every time they
give birth so few
few children
children at
a time and it takes them a while
to give birth to those children and they
take care of them for a while
now the other end of the spectrum you
have some of the things that we have
here you have
amphibians like frogs you have insects
you could imagine small fish bacteria
mosquitoes
that are more short-lived short
lived they have they tend to be
smaller
and they tend to have a lot of children
at a time
so lots of children
at a time just an example
a frog or what you see here is this is
spiders coming out of an
egg sac frogs or spiders
they can lay in many cases thousands of
eggs at a time
and they're not really dependent on any
one of those eggs necessarily surviving
many of them will be killed off by
predators but as long as a few
survive then the next generation you can
imagine they get to reproduction and
then they'll lay
thousands of eggs and they're shorter
lived
a frog could live a few years some
insects might live
anywhere from a few days to a few years
you have things like bacteria that can
have an even shorter lifespan
so when biologists or ecologists look at
this they say it looks like there is a
spectrum over here
you have these large long-lived animals
that have a few children at a time and
really the limiting factor
on their population is how dense their
population is at some point
these animals are going to compete for
resources with each other and that's
true of things like human beings
at the other end you have these things
like spiders or
frogs instead they might be limited on
their reproduction by environmental
factors like
how moist or dry it is how hot or cold
it is
and so generally speaking folks have
attempted to classify
these types of species they call them k
selected i'll talk about
where the k comes from in a second and
they talk about these types of species
as r selected
and where these letters come from is
that there's a general
idea that if we draw a little axis here
time
and then drop axis here population
on the vertical axis most species that
when there's not a lot of them and
they're not limited by
resources they will grow exponentially
like this
now when you go into the math of it that
rate of growth is usually denoted by the
letter
r and you could see where this r
selected is coming from and
what that r is how large it is is
determined by
a species biotic potential
and biotic potential just means in a
given environment
how quickly can they reproduce what
percentage of those are able to
get to maturity so that they can
reproduce etc etc
and so you can imagine the higher the r
the faster
this exponential growth goes up now at
some point
you're going to be resource constrained
and some there's some carrying capacity
and so let's say this is the carrying
capacity here and let's call that
k and the reason why we use k instead of
c is k comes from a word for capacity in
german so at some point you're going to
get you're going to have so many things
that you're just not going to have
enough resources to support
more and so your population would
flatten out
something like this and so generally
speaking
biologists have categorized these left
categories of species
as k selected they are the amount that
you have the amount of population is
going to be determined
by the resources that are there the
carrying capacity in the environment
while things like frogs and mosquitoes
and bacteria and spiders
you view more as are selected they're
going to grow
exponentially at their biotic potential
but that biotic potential is going to be
determined by how hot or cold or wet or
dry or other environmental factors
they're not going to get to such a high
density that they're really competing
with each other
now as you can imagine with most
categorizations
nature is not that clean that things are
always going to be on the left side are
always going to be on the right side
for example things like turtles lay a
lot of eggs but they live
a very long time it's also worth noting
that there's no value judgment that one
strategy
is better than the other they've both
been successful the fact that these
species exist today
show that they have worked well it is
worth noting that invasive species
tend to be more r selected they will
just grow and grow and grow are going to
be limited by the
environment and not as much by each
other while k-selected species
are often the ones that are most
affected by invasive species
now the last thing i want to highlight
is what we just talked about is
population
growth strategies and that can sometimes
be confused
with niche strategies where are there
certain species that are generalists
that can occupy many different niches
while there's
certain species that are more
specialists here we're just talking
about generally speaking
how do species tend to grow in
population while when we talk about
niche strategies we're going to talk
about the types of niches they fill
in order to get their resources and
we'll talk more about all of that
in future videos